hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about antibiogram z-- so
antibiogram are resources that show how
susceptible a certain species of
bacteria is to specific antibiotics we
know that antibiotic resistance is a
problem and it's a growing problem and
that difference
Easy's of bacteria and even different
strains of bacteria can be resistant to
different antibiotics and which
antibiotics will work in which
antibiotics won't work is not always
easily apparent without testing and so
antibiogram are basically an
accumulation of local data so this is
where all of the data from a given
hospital or a given clinic or
occasionally a given community are
compiled into one sort of database or
publication for doctors to use so that
doctors can monitor trends in resistance
in a given clinical setting so that a
doctor can know hey this species of
bacteria we're seeing a lot of cases in
this hospital and they're all resistant
to this one antibiotic I better start
prescribing another antibiotic and so
these antibiogram czar used by doctors
to assess the frequency how often a
particular antibiotic is effective
against the particular species and this
is just to aid in decision making so to
help doctors make decisions about what
antibiotic to describe so for example
here I've got an example table keep in
mind that an actual antibiogram is going
to be very very large it's going to look
at probably dozens of different
antibiotics against a huge number of
microbial species and so we're just
looking here at a sort of a small
example so for a given species percent s
means the percent of isolates so
basically the percent of isolates from
any number of patients that were
susceptible to the antibiotic so you can
see that for whatever species this is
zero percent were susceptible to
amoxicillin
so amoxicillin didn't it wasn't
effective against any of those isolates
and is the sample size how many isolates
had been tested so with forty two
isolates taken from forty two patients
amoxicillin did work against any of them
there were six isolates that were tested
with cephalosporin and 35% of those
isolates were susceptible to
cephalosporin any other roughly
two-thirds were not with ciprofloxacin
you had 99.8% susceptibility and 514
isolates that's great because that's a
large sample size 514 isolates and
almost all of them were susceptible
so a doctor is gonna look at this and
say amoxicillin is probably a bad idea
against this particular species of
bacteria ciprofloxacin on the other hand
looks like a good effect so that's what
I'm going to prescribe some antibiotics
regions so these this is often referred
to as the mi see so the minimum
inhibitory concentrations are mi sees
these are the lowest concentration in
each drug that prevents growth of each
type of bacteria so in an antibiogram in
addition to the percent susceptible into
the sample size there might also be
information
on just how much like what concentration
of these drugs was needed to fully
inhibit the growth of that particular
bacterium so that helps the doctor not
just know which antibiotic they're going
to prescribe but at which dosage there's
a couple of caveats to keep in mind one
is to take into account patient history
if a patient contracts a disease when
they're at Disney World in Florida and
then they fly home to Montana and that's
where they go to the doctor a doctor
using an anti-violence there in say
Bozeman Montana that's one of the may be
that helpful if the patient actually
picked up that bacterial infection in a
completely different location so taking
into account where the patient's been
can be really helpful also keep in mind
that doctors can use other resources in
addition to antibiogram so for example
they can do a disk diffusion test also
known as the Kerby bauer method or Kirby
Bower test I have another video on the
Kirby Bower test if that's something
you're interested in checking out but
that's a way to take an actual isolate
from a patient and test it against
multiple antibiotics to see which
antibiotics are most effective and so
you can actually use those two methods
kind of in conjunction what I mean by
that is a doctor can consult an anti
diagram decide to use ciprofloxacin
prescribe ciprofloxacin but also take
the isolate from that patient test it
with a disk diffusion assay and they
might find in doing that that this
particular isolate unlike the other
99.8% it happens to be in that point two
percent that are resistant to
ciprofloxacin the doctor might at that
point say oh hang on ciprofloxacin is
not going to work for this particular
patients
isolate even though it was the best
guest based on the accumulation of all
of our local data it's not the best
treatment for this patient and so I'm
going to prescribe something else
instead if you're interested in learning
more about antibiotic resistance I've
got a video on that you can check out
you can also check out my video on the
diffusion test to learn more about how
that's carried out if you're interested
in antibiotics and mechanisms ways that
we can help fight antibiotic resistance
you can also check out my video on
penicillin and cloudy Atlantic acid
which is a pretty cool topic I think so
that's it for today thanks for watching
biology professor